que j'ouvre notre second débat vous le
savez on cherche le plus souvent
possible à le décaler volontairement de
l'actualité du jour il est consacré ce
soir au super riche les milliardaires
français sont de plus en plus nombreuses
de plus en plus riches aussi et tout en
haut du classement mondial on trouve
aussi l'anneau compatriotes le patron de
LVMH Bernard Arnault faut-il s'enrichir
ou au contraire faire de la France un
pays sans milliardaires comme le
souhaite Jean-Luc Mélenchon ou marine
Tondelier pop écologie vert avant de
débattre zoom sur ces richesses qui
donnent le tournis quand un Calmet
Jérôme
c'est une grande première pour la France
dans son palmarès 2023 le magazine
Forbes se présente Bernard Arnault et
Françoise bettencourmeyers comme l'homme
et la femme les plus riches du monde ils
sont au total 43 milliardaires dans
l'Hexagone et plus largement depuis les
années 80 les riches sont de plus en
plus riches comme l'expliquent cette
économie la richesse donc ce qu'on
possède ça peut être des biens
immobiliers mais c'est aussi beaucoup du
patrimoine financier des actions
d'entreprise et de plus en plus
concentré dans les pays riches et la
France ne fait pas du tout exception à
ce phénomène pourtant pour répartir ces
richesses des mécanismes ont été mis en
place un pot de solidarité sur la
fortune tranche d'imposition progressive
ou encore imposition de l'héritage mais
ces dernières années après l'échec de la
taxation à 75% des revenus au dessus de
1 million d'euros sous François Hollande
l'heure est plutôt à la fin de la
taxation des hauts revenus Emmanuel
Macron a supprimé l'ISF rempl réalisé
par l'impôt sur la fortune immobilière
et selon l'Institut des Études publiques
ce sont bien les plus riches qui ont
profité du premier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron plus 2,8% de hausse de
pouvoir d'achat pour les 1% les plus
riches et même plus 4 % pour les 0,1%
des Français les plus aisés pourtant au
niveau international leur semble retour
de la taxation des plus revenus les
super riches doivent commencer à payer
leur juste par d'impôts il est grand
temps je ne cherche pas à punir qui que
ce soit je suis un capitaliste tout ce
que je demande c'est que vous payez
votre juste part
ce qui fait dire à certains que la
France est à contretemps
absolument pas compris le moment de
l'histoire économique dans lequel on est
et qui se retrouve à faire du Regan 1984
alors qu'en fait on est en 2023 au delà
des 43 milliardaires français recensés
par Forbes le nombre de Français dont le
patrimoine dépasse un million d'euros
intéresse également ils étaient près de
2,8 millions en France en 2021 et selon
le Crédit Suisse ils seront presque 4
millions en 2026
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités stanislasanoon bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes responsable des
campagnes justice fiscales et inégalités
chez Oxfam France Fabrice Almeida
bonsoir bienvenue historien auteur de ce
livre Histoire mondial des riches qui
est publiées aux éditions plonges
accueille également Richard berlibois
en France Europe pour le média Suisse
Blic et Mathieu croissanto et hitoris
politique et toujours là rebonsoir
Mathieu le constat peut-être pour
commencer sur le nombre de milliardaires
en France selon le magazine forbs 43
milliardaires recensés et surtout c'est
peut-être encore plus intéressant la
fortune des milliardaires français a
augmenté de 58% depuis 2020 et ça et
c'est un c'est votre rapport aux femmes
qui nous donne ce chiffre Stanis à nous
comment elle s'explique cette
progression ça ça correspond à une
hausse de plus de 200 milliards d'euros
depuis 2020 alors effectivement ce qu'on
a observé c'est que depuis 2020 donc
depuis la pandémie on assiste à une
accélération des inégalités et
évidemment c'est pour la plupart la
l'injection par les banques centrales de
milliards d'euros pour sauver l'économie
qui a fait que de facto les
milliardaires ont ensuite en profiter
puisque ils sont très souvent détenteurs
d'action et ou propriétaire de ces
entreprises et c'est ce qui a fait que
leur croissance a vu une fulgurance donc
c'est d'abord les bons résultats de
leurs entreprises et finalement le cours
de leurs actions qui explique en partie
cette explosion de richesse c'est
complètement ça puisque ça vous a pas
échappé l'économie s'est arrêté durant
la pandémie et on a vu que typiquement
si on parle de Bernard Arnault Bernard
Arnault et LVMH n'a pas vendu plus de
sac à main durant la pandémie puisque de
fait les magasins étaient fermés et
c'est bien le cours de l'action et ce
qui détient comme part qui a vu cette
accélération oui parce que quand on
parle juste de fortune des milliardaires
on parle de valorisation du patrimoine
capitalistique un tenté bien sûr c'est
pas de l'argent qu'ils ont en banque
c'est la valeur de l'entreprise et le
nombre de parts qu'il possède c'est ça
alors oui le bémol c'est que typiquement
si on prend l'exemple de ce qu'on
effectivement c'est un argument qui
revient beaucoup si on prend Elon Musk
qui on a on avait été numéro un mondiale
pas très longtemps supporté par Bernard
parce qu'on a constaté c'est que il
avait pu racheter notamment Twitter avec
des actions Tesla donc on voit bien que
finalement cette idée que c'est des
actions un petit peu flottantes et que
c'est pas vraiment leur argent
finalement ils peuvent quand même s'en
servir pour acheter des biens et des
entreprises ça c'est important de le
rappeler pour montrer que c'est ça reste
quand même une fortune qui lui a permis
d'acheter une entreprise oui mais c'est
pas c'est pas un achat enfin c'est pas
un nouveau yacht ou vous voyez ce que je
veux dire c'est de l'investissement
entrepreneur il y a après on peut on
peut juger de ce qui fait de Twitter ou
pas j'ai décidé de quitter Twitter mais
bon ça c'est un autre débat qu'on a déjà
eu sur ce plateau Fabrice d'Almeida dans
vous dites que l'anathème jeté contre
les grandes fortunes est un non-sens
pourquoi il vous dit ça parce que moi
j'ai dit ça peut-être je l'ai dit en
tout cas je pense c'est que la façon
qu'on a eu de les juger depuis le 19e
siècle parce qu'en fait les riches c'est
ça émerge avec la révolution
industrielle ça émerge avec le
libre-échange dans la deuxième moitié du
19e siècle ça s'accélère dans les années
80 avec le néolibéralisme qui facilite
la circulation qui facilite encore la
financarisation mais ce qu'il y a de de
Claire c'est que on a eu tendance à les
juger comme un groupe hyper compact
solidaire une classe sociale opposée à
une autre classe sociale les prolétaires
qui n'avaient rien et en fait le
sentiment que j'ai c'est qu'aujourd'hui
ce regard là est plus un obstacle à voir
ce qui se passe et éventuellement même à
effectuer de nouvelles formes de
taxation que d'essayer de regarder
j'allais dire de façon singulière pour
voir ce que chacun apporte à l'histoire
apporte à la société apporte à
l'humanité ou au contraire à comme
impact négatif sur les sociétés donc
vous dites que de mettre tous les riches
dans le même dans le même cas c'est
caricatural j'ai même l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui c'est contre-productif
pour obtenir vraiment une une taxation
efficace je pense que c'est plus
efficace de le faire comme une partie
des Américains le font en disant qui
polluent doit payer plus donc il
produisent plus il polluent plus ils
doivent payer plus qui voilà émet en
regardant bien précisément quels sont
ceux qui en termes éthiques
des vis où sont des prédateurs dans
notre société Richard wernis ce débat
sur les super riches il est il est
passionnant ils font il prend une
résonance évidemment particulière avec
le double contexte ou la conjonction
inflation réforme des retraites
notamment en France oui alors il est
d'abord assez spécifique à la France
quand même le débat sur la richesse
disons dans son anim parce que le fond
de sauce il est quand même celui là on
n'aime pas les riches ou en tout cas on
les jette en pâture on cite les noms il
y a des films des documentaires c'est
quand même très à charge sur les riches
en France et ça il faut connaître que
c'est pas le cas dans la plupart des
pays européens notamment ceux qui
entourent la France c'est pas le cas en
Suisse ça ne vous étonnera pas mais
c'est pas le cas dans un pays comme les
Pays-Bas par exemple où était récemment
Emmanuel Macron au contraire les
Pays-Bas font tout pour attirer les
quartiers généraux des très grandes
multinationales et donc les grandes
fortunes qui sont les dirigeants à la
tête ces multinationales alors
effectivement dans le cadre de précis en
France dans ce moment conjoncturel c'est
encore plus aigu et je dirais que c'est
encore plus aigu parce qu'il y a une
chose que j'ai découverte en France
c'est que une grande partie de cette
animosité elle est liée aussi parce que
ces grandes fortunes quelquefois on fait
la fortune grâce à l'argent public c'est
ce que vous disiez à l'instant c'est à
dire que par exemple Bernard Arnault
c'est vrai de Bernard Arnault exactement
et donc les Français le savent ils
savent que ces énormes fortunes n'ont
pas été simplement le résultat de
l'ingéniosité de Monsieur Bernard
Arnault mais de sa capacité à mobiliser
les fonds publics au moment où il en
avait besoin à s'enrichir sur les fonds
publics et à ce moment-là il faut
reconnaître que la question de la
redistribution elle est plus légitime
que si par exemple il avait été un
startupeur Américain porté par le
capitaliste à l'américaine qu'on connaît
vous pouvez répéter mais j'ai pas bien
entendu il faut quand même dire une
réalité c'est que la France a été très
longtemps sous capitaliser jusqu'aux
années 80 c'est-à-dire que c'est les
réformes Bérégovoy qui font que l'argent
s'investit dans le marché boursier
auparavant en réalité on a des
participations croisées de société
d'État de société privée enfin je dis ça
c'est pas pour particulièrement défendre
tel ou tel non mais ça existe encore
aujourd'hui il y a un organisme qui
s'occupe la BPI la banque publique
d'investissement qui aide les start-up à
grandir à devenir des licornes etc pour
devenir la plus grande fortune mondiale
je pense quand même qu'il faut avoir
quelques qualités je pense je pense que
personne ne contredit ça
je reviens sur votre sur votre dernier
rapport Stanislas Saloun sur le parce
que moi j'ai été surpris par ce chiffre
le fait que les riches captent
l'essentiel de la de la richesse
mondiale à à quel point 1% des riches
alors donc 1% des tiennes de les deux
tiers des richesses mondiales ça c'est
le chiffre qu'on a sorti au mois de
janvier et effectivement enfin je
rejoins ce que vous diriez sur le fait
que il s'agit pas d'être anti riche de
manière comme ça dogmatique ce qui est
important c'est vraiment la
redistribution et pour vous donner un
ordre de grandeur et pour revenir aussi
sur le côté inflation les réformes des
retraites un chiffre intéressant les 10
premiers milliardaires français en
janvier donc ça a peut-être un petit peu
changé mais en janvier les 10 premiers
milliardaires français détenaient
environ 187 milliards d'euros de hausse
de fortune de PI 2020 ce qui était en
fait l'équivalent de deux ans de facture
énergétique des Français des Françaises
donc dans le contexte actuel social avec
la réforme des retraite mais aussi plus
généralement avec le fait que depuis un
an plus d'un an maintenant la hausse des
prix surtout pour les denrées
alimentaires explosent ça pose question
et effectivement il y a un vrai souci de
redistribution et non pas juste de
pointer du doigt et pardonalise c'est
qu'on n'est pas on ne vise pas par
exemple les 10% les plus riches on est
vraiment sur les Ultra riches et donc
c'est les 1% ou même 0,1 % qui sont
vraiment qui sont en fait dès leviers de
changement de alors moi j'essaye de
simplifier et quand je parlais de 43
milliardaires c'est c'est donc français
ce sont de ces deux dont vous nous
parlez exactement notamment il y a aussi
des millionnaires on les oublie mais oui
mais c'est la question du seuil où on
place le seuil on est toujours le riche
de quelqu'un effectivement c'est les
milliards ont évidemment on a vu avec
Bernard Arnault et et François
bezancourt qui sont les donc les deux
personnes les plus riches du monde
évidemment pardon Bernard Arnault pour
les hommes française bientôt cours pour
les femmes voilà tout à fait parité et
du coup voilà donc c'est un vrai enjeu
il y a un levier d'action pour nous
notamment sur les sujets de réforme
fiscale mais on pourra en parler après
et ben on va en parler tout de suite
vous savez la réforme fiscale parce que
c'est évidemment la question qui qui se
pose pour rééquilibrer et je propose que
Steve Jourdain nous rejoignent de
nouveau sur le plateau de sens public
rebonsoir Steve bonsoir puisque le
Parlement cet automne s'est penché à
plusieurs reprises sur cette question
d'une taxe visant les plus riches
c'était pendant l'examen du budget pour
l'année 2023 les hostilités ont commencé
à l'Assemblée nationale Thomas ou les
oppositions ont tirées à boulets rouges
sur la politique fiscale d'Emmanuel
Macron elles ont notamment cibler l'ISF
l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune qui
a été supprimée en 2018 remplacé par
l'IFI un impôt sur la fortune
immobilière la gauche a dénoncé
l'injustice de cette décision
un peu de solidarité sur la fortune sa
suppression est devenue le symbole de la
politique prorige que vous avez mené
pendant 5 ans et que vous continuez
encore maintenant je veux le redire ici
le président des riches et l'ennemi des
pauvres Chelon après une heure et demie
de débat électrique dans l'hémicycle les
8 amendements déposés par les
oppositions pour rétablir l'ISF ont tous
été rejetés par l'Assemblée nationale
voilà c'est parti l'opposition qui ont
également voulu taxer les yachts et les
jet privés oui plusieurs amendements
avaient été déposés au Sénat par les
groupes de gauche au mois de novembre on
va regarder par exemple le texte proposé
par les socialistes si la question est
écologique c'est aussi une question de
justice fiscale et sociale comment faire
accepter aux françaises et aux Français
la sobriété nécessaire dans le cadre de
la transition énergique énergétique
pendant qu'on parallèle une vie d'effort
d'un Français moyen peut-être effacé par
moi d'une heure de navigation d'un
supérieur d'un multimilliardaire point
d'interrogation fin de citation la
réponse du gouvernement à ces
propositions de taxation a été la même à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat
Seignette écoutez deux lignes
différentes et de vision différentes
vous proposez de taxer pour résoudre les
problèmes nous au contraire ce qu'on
veut c'est investir moi je préfère qu'on
dépense de l'argent pour investir dans
l'avion va carbone dans des navires qui
polluent moins même avec des amendements
ou avec lesquels j'étais pas totalement
en accord tout à l'heure plutôt que de
créer des taxes à faiblement ou c'est
super on va recruter plein de
fonctionnaires pour des taxes qui
rapporteront pas grand chose pour les
calculer et les recouvrer qui ne
changeront absolument rien en pratique
que vous évoquez on le voit de ligne de
vision le gouvernement lui a décidé de
cibler non pas les Ultra riches mais
certaines entreprises il a fait passer
une taxe alors je vais dire contre les
supers profits dans le budget 2023 sauf
que c'est pas tout à fait il y a eu
beaucoup de débats sur le titre de cette
impôt proposé par le gouvernement et
adopté par le Parlement officiellement
il ne s'agit pas d'une taxe car Emmanuel
Macron a promis de ne pas augmenter les
impôts mais d'une contribution
temporaire de solidarité voilà appeler
ça comme vous voulez c'est en fait la
traduction de notre droit d'une mesure
adoptée au niveau européen au mois de
septembre est cible les entreprises de
l'énergie qui ont vu leur profit
exploser à la suite de la guerre en
Ukraine elles seront taxées à 33% au
lieu de 25% écoutez Bruno mais à ce
sujet
contacts les super profits des
énergéticiens parce que les prix
explosent oui et si ça plaît à certains
qu'on empêche le mot très bien c'est ce
que nous faisons je rappelle que le
mécanisme de rente inframarginal pour
prendre le teint de technique
c'est-à-dire tout ce qu'on récupère sur
la ronde des énergéticiens ça va nous
rapporter 26 milliards d'euros en 2023
nous rapporter beaucoup moins que 26
milliards 26 c'est au niveau européen en
France on peut espérer récupérer jusqu'à
4 milliards d'euros selon les différents
estimations les principaux contributeurs
seront les entreprises Esso et total
énergie merci beaucoup Steve je démarre
sur la question de l'ISF avec vous
Richard Werly on l'a déjà évoqué dans
notre premier débat d'ailleurs parce que
en fait ça revient à quoi ça revient à
l'occasion de la réforme des retraites
c'est quoi c'est un peu le sparadrap du
capitaine Haddock pour Emmanuel Macron
ça ça lui colle au basket quel que soit
la partie de son de son costume quoi
vous savez il y a rien de plus dur je
crois que d'effacer les symboles et
c'était un symbole l'ISF un peu de
solidarité sur la fortune et il est
resté le son son abrogation est resté
comme la preuve selon ceux qui
voudraient le rétablir qu'Emmanuel
Macron est le président des riches et ça
c'est extrêmement compliqué à je dirais
à supprimer dans la mémoire collective
et puis il y a cette réalité encore une
fois très française parce que ce n'est
pas vrai dans les pays européens qui
entourent la France c'est que le riche
quelque part doit être je dirais pas
puni mais presque on est presque quand
même dans la punition c'est-à-dire
l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune et
vu comme une juste punition par rapport
au niveau de vie qu'il a pu acquérir ça
vous savez quand c'est dans l'imaginaire
collectif effectivement c'est très dur à
enlever et je crois qu'Emmanuel Macron
clairement malgré ce que ça rapportait
peut-être il n'a pas réussi à mettre en
valeur ce que ça rapportait ou peut-être
que simplement son abrogation n'a pas
rapporté autant que le président le
pensait c'est un symbole parce que
Madame Macron a voulu que ce soit un
symbole faut savoir que de la même façon
que le paquet fiscal avait été la
première décision politique du
quinquennat Sarkozy cette suppression
d'ISF a été une des premières décisions
du premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
et c'était voulu parce que il y a aussi
en France et il faut l'entendre une
petite musique qui veut que il faut il y
a un chantage en gros de la part de
d'ultra riches qui est si vous nous
traitez mal on s'en va c'est quand même
quelque chose qu'on entend depuis tout
le temps Nicolas Sarkozy avait basé son
quinquennat à l'idée en disant il faut
faire revenir les riches il faut les
réimpatrier je peux quitter le mot qui
l'employait de la rapatriation de de
patrimoine parce que nos riches s'en
vont il y a aussi autre chose en France
c'est qu'il y a une forme de de
distorsion depuis 20 ans une espèce de
pensée qui s'impose et qui n'est jamais
remise en cause parce qu'elle fait
partie de ce qu'on appelait autrefois le
cercle de la raison qui est que les
pauvres doivent toujours s'aligner sur
les plus pauvres c'est à dire vous êtes
ouvrier français vous devez baisser vos
salaires parce que les Roumains puis les
Chinois travaillent pour moins cher et
les riches doivent toujours singulier
vers le haut sur les plus riches vous
êtes patrons du CAC 40 vous dites moi
faut que je sois payé comme les
américains parce que mon marché est
concurrentiel comme si on avait vu
la boîte américaine se battent pour les
patrons français donc ces espèces de
refrains qu'on nous sereine depuis 20
ans depuis 30 ans agace aussi au bout
d'un moment et soulève des questions à
mon avis qui sont légitimes alors
ensuite on n'est pas obligé d'y répondre
de façon caricaturale ou excessive il
s'agit de couper la tête à personne mais
moi je pense qu'on est moins dans la
punition que dans la redistribution
après la France a aussi un pays
catholique
puisque comme vous le savez un certain
nombre de riches trouve asiles en Suisse
c'est encore vrai aujourd'hui pour des
raisons fiscales mais c'est vrai que
l'émotion suscité par la richesse est
moindre en Suisse parce que les salaires
vous avez tout à fait raison sont
beaucoup plus élevés on sait en France
on est là et puis on a un rapport
l'argent dans ce pays qui est le même
que la Suisse Fabrice sur la question du
du salaire parce que ça revient aussi
dans ce débat le salaire des grands
patrons notamment ça c'est ressorti dans
l'actualité avec le patron de stellantis
qui sont son conseil d'administration le
3,5 millions d'euros voilà lui a donné
un joli salaire mais en même temps ce
qu'il a fait de ce lentilles c'est quand
même des succès dans le milieu
automobile depuis ces 10 dernières
années donc voilà j'essaye j'essaye
d'être un peu équilibré dans ma façon
d'en parler mais je me souviens d'une je
crois que c'était dans les années 20
c'était à la banque JP Morgan on disait
le patron ne doit pas gagner 20 fois
plus que le salaire le plus bas de la
banque ça a volé en éclat depuis combien
de temps ça
la question que vous posez c'est la
question du seuil de richesse en gros
quoi donc on peut discuter est-ce qu'on
est riche à partir du moment où on
touche des émoluments c'est une vraie
question traditionnellement on disait
que le riche était le rentier en fait
celui qui vivait des intérêts de son
capital on peut dire qu'aujourd'hui on
en est plus là aujourd'hui pour moi
riche vie des intérêts des intérêts voir
des intérêts de son capital c'est-à-dire
que on a des niveaux de de fortune et de
rémunération aujourd'hui qui sont
tellement énormes enfin pour se rendre
compte il y a quelques jours Bernard
Arnault en une seule journée a gagné 14
milliards
sur sa valeur boursière 14 milliards en
une journée donc c'est des c'est on a
atteint des chiffres parce qu'il y a eu
comme vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure une
telle fabrication de masse monétaire au
moment du covid enfin passionnant
d'ailleurs ça a commencé en 2016 ça
c'est répété plusieurs fois donc on a
tellement augmenté la masse monétaire
qu'en réalité on a eu des éponges à
milliards qui sont les ultra-riches et
si on regarde d'ailleurs la croissance
du nombre de milliards des 43
milliardaires en gros autour de 200
milliards je crois qu'on a injecté à
l'époque dans du covid 250 milliards
dans l'économie française donc j'allais
dire le rapport est tellement évident
qu'on a vraiment l'impression qu'on a
fait une éponge pour éviter quoi en
réalité et c'est ce qui est en train de
se libérer aujourd'hui pour éviter
l'inflation or le seul moyen qu'on a
aujourd'hui pour
baisser la part de capitalisation des
riches
où la part de la dette parce que pour
dépenser ces 250 milliards on a fait de
la dette c'est justement l'inflation et
c'est terrible parce que l'inflation va
commencer par laminer les pauvres bien
sûr avant qu'on mette enfin en place et
c'est pour ça que j'en veux un petit peu
au gouvernement aujourd'hui c'est
normalement il devrait jouer le jeu
justement de faire suivre les salaires
parce qu'à ce moment-là effectivement en
valeur relative ça fait baisser la part
de la dette ça fait baisser la part des
fortunes et là il y a un vrai problème
qu'on a en France c'est qu'on reste
coincé sur l'idée bariste qu'on doit
casser l'inflation or aujourd'hui elle
nous est indispensable cette année ça
nous peut-être pour revenir à la
fiscalité quelle solution vous vous
proposez chez Oxfam rétablir l'ISF une
nouvelle forme de DSF de toute façon
générale nous ce qu'on veut c'est taxé
le patrimoine net donc ce qui en fait
c'est ce que le Crédit Suisse utilise
comme indicateur pour justement mesurer
la richesse de ces milliardaires et des
suisses dont on a vu les performances
bancaires récemment
qui viennent
le patrimoine c'est c'est la c'est on
enlève la dette c'est l'équivalent de
tout ce qui est patrimoine financier et
patrimoine immobilier on envoie la dette
donc ça correspond à la richesse c'est
vraiment ce que le Crédit Suisse utilise
donc j'ai oublié votre question pardon
est-ce qu'il faut rétablir l'ISF alors
et donc alors évidemment nous on est
pour un rétablissement de l'ISF mais du
coup en enlevant quelques failles qui
avait pu être
observé lors du quinquennat Hollande on
est également pour et ça c'est
extrêmement important par les temps qui
courent on est pour rajouter des malus
indexées sur le le la pollution des
malus lié à la à la à la pollution à
l'empreinte carbone pardon des de du
patrimoine de 6 milliardaires ça c'est
une chose et évidemment il y a d'autres
mesures qui sont liées à l'évasion
fiscale dont on n'a pas parlé mais qui
est
[Musique]
et il avait estimé lui ça à 200 millions
d'euros nous on a plutôt évalué ça à une
recette potentielle de 10 à 20 milliards
d'euros fabriz elmada
de fiscalité faut savoir pourquoi si
c'est pour aider les pauvres ça me
paraît indispensable c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a effectivement et on
a vu il y a différents rapports le vôtre
notamment qui montre ça on est dans une
situation où il y a une nouvelle
précarité qui est en train de se mettre
en place et de s'installer donc il y a
besoin de secours donc faire une
fiscalité spécifique pour ça qui peut
durer un an qui peut durer deux ans ça
peut se discuter mais on aurait à faire
à une action qui serait délimitée et
clairement fait dans le temps mais il y
a un autre une autre musique que
j'entends en fond qui est l'idée que il
faut de la taxation pour l'égalité comme
si en fait l'égalité était en soi une
valeur qui allait être forcément
positive pour nous alors que on s'est
battu en fait pendant un demi siècle le
demi siècle dernier pour qui est plus de
liberté pour qu'on ait plus de marge de
manœuvre et ça c'est une question que je
me pose en quoi est-ce que
quête qu'un certain nombre de parties et
d'organisations veulent d'une fiscalité
pour l'égalité va améliorer le
fonctionnement d'un CC aujourd'hui
sincèrement je n'en suis pas sûr Richard
Verdier je vous propose de revoir le
la photo de Bernard Arnault qui est donc
officiellement aujourd'hui l'homme le
plus riche du monde alors 211 milliards
de dollars c'était le le dernier
classement qui a été donné évidemment ça
fluctue on l'a dit en fonction de du
cours de des actions LVMH
en voyant une nouvelle comme ça dans
beaucoup de pays on se dirait chouette
l'homme le plus riche du monde des
Français
mais c'est vrai ça arrivera en Suisse
aux États-Unis aux États-Unis
moi je suis jamais jaloux des gens qui
ont plus d'argent que moi donc j'ai pas
de problème avec ça mais mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a une large part de l'opinion
oui et mais je pense encore une fois
avec des spécificités dans le cadre
Bernard Arnault d'abord moi je me
souviens j'ai des correspondre à
Bruxelles au moment où il l'avait dit
qu'il allait s'établir en Belgique ne
l'oublions pas donc il y avait une femme
où on a dit qu'il y pensait mais
je savais pas qu'il avait des menti mais
il me semble que c'était quand même
assez sérieux toujours est-il que il y a
quand même derrière le personnage de
Bernard Arnault se soupçon de ne pas
vouloir assumer sa fortune ou là où je
disons assumer la redistribution qui va
avec même si je crois qu'au sein de son
groupe les salaires sont tout à fait
bons et qu'il y a beaucoup d'efforts de
la part de LVMH pour soutenir
l'entrepreneuriat d'art en France donc
il y a une on peut pas je crois
dissocier de la richesse et c'est là où
je voulais en venir le caractère des
personnalités par exemple en Suisse ou
vous le savez on n'a pas trop de
problèmes avec les riches mais il y a un
problème avec les oligarques russes le
pays a accueilli quantité de ligaurus ou
leur famille et les milliards qui vont
avec et aujourd'hui il y a vraiment une
rébellion sociale en Suisse à propos de
ces gens dont on estime qu'ils ont
profité du système que peut-être ils ont
amené un certain degré de corruption
dont il va falloir se défaire et etc etc
donc on ne peut pas je dirais quand même
mettre tous les milliardaires dans le
même sac et les fortunes ne se
ressemblent pas toutes et les fortunes
n'ont pas la même incidence sur la vie
des sociétés et toutes ces fortunes je
dirais ne sont pas réinvestis dans la
même manière dans le plan social ce qui
frappant quand vous allez aux États-Unis
on le sait tous Fabrice qui fréquente
beaucoup les universités vous avez
énormément de milliardaires qui ont leur
haul dans les universités leurs
amphithéâtres qui ont des laboratoires
de recherche etc c'est on peut contester
on peut discuter de ça mais au moins
c'est une forme de redistribution il y
en a d'autres qui ne redistribuent pas
du tout j'ai en tête le le patron de
Patagonia je crois c'est un grand groupe
amerrir lui il est américain d'origine
québécoise je suis en train de ils vont
Chouinard je crois il a il a décidé de
léguer son entreprise un trust et à une
ONG en disant tous les bénéfices de
l'entreprise maintenant seront
redistribués pourquoi pour
se sauver la planète en quelque sorte je
simplifie mais c'est l'idée mais c'est
la différence entre Steve Jobs et Bill
Gates Steve Jobs très donateurs Bill
Gates énorme donateurs il y a aussi des
millionnaires qui ont signé une lettre
deux ans de suite pour pour demander à
être beaucoup plus taxé notamment il y a
l'héritière de Disney par exemple qui a
demandé on a justement l'un de ces
millionnaires il est britannique qui
s'appelle fil White et il fait partie
d'un groupe qui s'appelle les
millionnaires Patriotes du Royaume-Uni
et alors il a il a bien choisi le lieu
et le moment pour rappeler cette demande
d'être plus taxé par les gouvernements
il a fait où au Forum de Davos
je m'appelle Phil White et je suis venu
de Londres adavos pour cet événement je
suis membre des millionnaires Patriotes
du Royaume-Uni
un groupe de personnes fortunées qui
pensent que nous devrions réduire les
niveaux de richesse et que les
gouvernements devraient imposer des
taxes sur la richesse afin de réduire
les inégalités et d'avoir une société
plus juste une école que je viens c'est
pourquoi je suis ici aujourd'hui à la
conférence du
wesh bon moralité on essaie de pas
mettre tous les milliard dans le dans le
même panier Mathieu on va s'intéresser
au discours politique autour de la de la
figure du riche la haine des riches on
peut dire que c'est pas nouveau non
parce qu'on a entendu marine Tondelier
secrétaire nationale d'Europe Écologie
Les Verts qui dit qu'elle voudrait une
France 100 milliardaire mais c'est vrai
que c'est pas nouveau et ça finit
souvent par vous revenir en pleine
figure en fait comme un boomerang la
ndrich en politique car vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure Thomas on est toujours le
riche de quelqu'un et quand on met le
sujet sur le tapis c'est risqué je me
souviens d'un exemple François Hollande
qui en sait quelque chose lui qui
déclarait vous en souvenez dans un débat
télévisé en 2007 je n'aime pas les
riches j'en conviens alors après il
avait été sommet d'expliquer à quel
niveau on était riche à quel seuil on
atterris il avait dit 4000 euros nets
mensuels ce qui correspondait à une
réalité statistique musculaire seulement
10% des Français à l'époque qui
gagnaient plus de 3500 euros net par
mois mais ce qui ne correspondait pas
vraiment à une réalité sociologique en
tout cas ce qui était un grand flou
parce que dans cette catégorie de 10%,
vous aviez aussi bien quelqu'un qui
gagne 3600 euros net que Bernard Arnault
puisque c'est les on est 10% les plus
riches et puis surtout ça lui a été
collé comme un sparadrap par la droite à
l'époque et ça embêtait celle qui était
s'accompagne à l'époque Ségolène Royal
qui a dû se justifier elle de payer
l'ISF a été candidate à la réalité
candidate à la présidentielle on le
rappelle et qui a eu cette pudeur en
forme d'aveugle faiblesse je ne suis pas
riche je suis aisé Jean-Luc Mélenchon
lui aussi a été victime de cet effet
boomerang oui Jean-Luc Mélenchon plus
récemment le 10 janvier sur France Info
dans un raccourci qui ressemble un peu à
sophisme Mathilde panot au chef de fil
des insoumis à l'Assemblée essayez de de
d'opposer les 70 % des Français qui
contestent la réforme des retraites au
19 ministres millionnaire que comptait
le gouvernement selon le dernier
décompte de la Haute Autorité en charge
de cela et puis là il y a un journaliste
sur le plateau qui s'appelle Marc Fauvel
notre collègue de France Info Jean-Luc
Mélenchon lui aussi et millionnaire et
c'est vrai depuis qu'il est candidat à
la présidentielle ces opposants ne
manque d'ailleurs jamais de de souligner
la valeur de son patrimoine lors de la
dernière élection présidentielle c'était
quatrième patrimoine Jean-Luc Mélenchon
avec 1,4 millions d'euros derrière
Valérie Pécresse derrière exembourg et
derrière Nicolas Dupont-Aignan or je
voulais dire attention on est toujours
le riche de quelqu'un et il y en a un
qui s'est saisi de ça c'est Gérald
Darmanin le ministre de l'Intérieur qui
s'est saisi de cet argument pour
fustiger les hypocrises de la nups
Monsieur Mélenchon est propriétaire d'un
patrimoine il est millionnaire je suis
très heureux pour lui je ne suis pas
jaloux disait-il moi je ne suis pas
millionnaire poursuivait Gérald daronne
je n'ai pas de patrimoine la seule chose
que mon légumes c'est le culte du
travail du mérite et de l'effort tout ça
est bien dégagé comme il faut mais en
tout cas c'était un peu la réponse du
berger à la bergère ça fait évidemment
sortir de ses gonds leader insoumis qui
a réagi dans un tweet le 17 février la
macronie rabâche la valeur de mon
appartement à Paris pour faire de moi la
figure du millionnaire parce qu'en fait
on parle là de richesse patrimoniale
immobilière de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et pas
d'argent de lingot d'or qui dort dans un
dans un compte en banque j'ai accumulé
il s'est fâché avant de s'en prendre à
qui à la mère de Paris j'ai accumulé
valeur grâce à Madame Hidalgo qui a fait
augmenter les prix de 350% en 10 ans
Jean-Luc Mélenchon millionnaire honteux
ou en tout cas millionnaire à l'insulte
son père gré comme disait l'autre merci
beaucoup Mathieu je reviens vers vous
Stanislas
est-ce qu'il y a un mouvement mondial
c'est à dire que vous Oxfam c'est une
c'est une ONG mondiale et donc il y a il
y a une volonté mondiale de taxer les
les super riches comment elle est reçue
en fonction des pays alors c'est une
bonne question on sait que au niveau
européen par exemple on a l'Espagne qui
est extrêmement en avance sur pas mal de
sujets sociétaux mais également fiscaux
on a on a une un sommet qui va se
dérouler en Colombie cet été sur un
sommet de réforme fiscales pour avec pas
mal de pays notamment d'Amérique du Sud
qui sont assez en pointe sur les enjeux
de fiscalité de réforme de la fiscalité
donc évidemment c'est un accueil diverse
chaque pays est un petit peu différent
on l'a vu en Europe tout le monde
n'était pas d'accord sur les assiettes
par exemple de fiscalité pour les super
Trophy donc on espère que avec quelques
pays notamment pourquoi pas en Amérique
du Sud on puisse avec un coup de billard
à trois bandes faire infléchir à la
politique européenne et pourquoi pas
françaises sur le sujet alors est-ce
qu'il nous est-ce qu'il faut inventer
une France 100 milliardaires au lait ok
Matthieu je pose pas la question par
hasard puisque c'est ce que souhaite
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il l'a dit plusieurs
fois mais aussi vous l'avez cité marine
tondelei est la secrétaire général
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts écoutaient
là
[Applaudissements]
sérieusement à quoi ça sert un
milliardaire on aurait pas eu seulement
c'est faux on nous répond il crée de
l'emploi non celles et ceux qui les
créent c'est nous c'est vous c'est le
monde du travail on nous dit que nous
devrions être fier d'avoir un géant LVMH
made in France mais les amis Bernard
Arnault a demandé la nationalité belge
pour que ses enfants ne payent pas de
droits de succession on nous dit qu'il
faut faire qu'il ne faut pas faire fuir
les talents mais ceux qui ont besoin de
plus d'un milliard ce ne sont pas des
talents ce sont des vampires ce ne sont
pas des génies ce sont des égoïstes
Fabrice Almeida est-ce qu'on est
forcément plus heureux dans un pays sans
milliardaire ben en tout cas si on
regarde le vert voilà si on regarde le
20e siècle les pays qui ont
systématiquement détruit leur richesse
et leur riches physiquement comme
l'Union soviétique entre 1917 et en gros
la deuxième guerre mondiale où on a
liquidé une classe sociale quand même il
y a un affaissement du niveau de vie
alors après on peut le récupérer plus
tard mais mais voilà pareil pour la
Chine après 1949 ou il y a la
destruction de toutes les lits
nationalistes qui avaient
œuvré notamment pour lutter contre le
Japon on constate aussi un affaissement
du niveau de vie avec des famines etc on
a pu voir ça aussi au Venezuela où il y
a eu une fuite récemment on a pu le voir
à Cuba de manière aussi aussi nette donc
quand on regarde ça au 20e siècle on
peut dire que ça fonctionne pas
maintenant je ne suis pas devin je ne
sais pas si à l'avenir il y aura pas une
méthode qui permettra de se passer
la secrétaire d'Europe Écologie Les
Verts dire ça parce que c'est vraiment
mais moi c'est vraiment dans le nouveau
peut-être pas nouveau mais en tout cas
c'est dans le discours écologique
aujourd'hui oui mais l'écologie en
France c'est beaucoup imposé par la
gauche il faut quand même le rappeler 60
70 et la gauche française c'est quand
même beaucoup construite soit en
opposition soit en accord complet avec
le marxisme et enfin je le répète et
souvent les gens me regardent avec un
air un peu ahuri mais enfin vous
connaissez beaucoup de pays dans le
monde où il y a la présidentielle de
candidats troskistes un candidat
communiste un candidat socialiste un
candidat écologiste et même les
populistes maintenant considèrent que
les riches c'est pas forcément bien donc
quand on regarde les parties qui sont
j'allais dire riches aux compatibles en
France il y en a très très peu très très
peu donc c'est j'allais dire pour le
coup je pense que c'est ça vient du fond
de notre culture
il y a
Emmanuel de varinskiel qui est un
historien qui disait ça remonte à la
révolution en fait c'est l'idée de
détruire les privilèges et avec ça
construire les patrimoine qui allaient
avec mais on a eu quand même un marxisme
extrêmement puissant et je crois que ce
qui s'est passé avec la deuxième guerre
mondiale et le mouvement de la
résistance en plus permis de définir les
riches comme les méchants collabos au
fond et c'est pas pour rien qu'on a eu
cette ce collect cette collectivisation
de l'économie au lendemain de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale est-ce que vous reprenez
le discours de de Jean-Luc Mélenchon de
marine dans le lien en disant on veut
une France 100 milliardaire alors
évidemment nous c'est un enfin non mais
ce qui est intéressant pour le coup
c'est quand même de dire que le
ruissellement qui a été beaucoup vendu
par Emmanuel Macron c'est vrai qu'on
envoie assez peu la couleur ça c'est
quand même un fait je veux dire si
c'était aussi simple que on avait ça
descendait vraiment sur les bas salaires
on a tout à l'heure par les salaires de
fait les salaires ont augmenté je crois
de 3,8% donc bien moins que l'inflation
donc on voit bien qu'il y a il y a pas
de réinvestissement dans les salaires
dans le travail par exemple et juste ce
qui est intéressant je reviens juste sur
le fait que on a on a parlé tout à
l'heure de la dette covid et de tous ces
milliards en fait pourquoi est-ce qu'on
parle beaucoup de ça pourquoi est-ce
qu'il y a beaucoup d'excitations par
rapport à ces milliardaires c'est aussi
le fait que le gouvernement essaye et
pas que froid enfin français n'est pas
que essaie de recouvrir recouvrir un
déficit qui donc à se creuser avec le
covid avec la dette covid notamment avec
la réforme des retraites dont on parle
beaucoup depuis plusieurs mois qui a une
réforme qui est contrairement à sa date
de 2019 et uniquement une réforme
budgétaire qui était amenée à avoir 12 à
20 milliards d'euros et on voit bien que
donc nous on a poussé ce chiffre un peu
pour montrer un un écart de grandeur
mais si on était amené à taxer c'est 42
milliards français à hauteur de 2% on
pourrait financer le système des
retraites c'est juste pour donner un
ordre d'idée et pour montrer qu'il y a
c'est des raccourcis qu'ils ont quand
même particulier parce que on rappelle
que ce qu'on disait au début c'est à
dire qu'on parle de capitalisation
boursière et de part d'une
capitalisation boursière c'est ça les
fortunes professionnels que vous
désignez et c'est vrai qu'il y a pas de
ruissellement automatique sur les
salaires et là je vous suis la théorie
du ruissellement marche pas forcément
mais il y a quand même aussi des
incidences ou des conséquences heureuses
en termes d'emploi on peut le dire le MH
est un groupe qui crée de l'emploi en
France et qui restructure ou soutient
des filières vous en parliez tout à
l'heure donc soit on parle pas d'un
rentier avec de l'argent qui dort et
faire la différence entre les héritiers
et fortune industrielles c'est pas une
fortune selon tes trébuchante à un
moment donné et c'est comme c'est une
capitalisation boursière on voit aussi
ce que l'entreprise fait vivre autour
d'elle et là pour le coup il y en a
quand la gauche est dans la haine à mon
avis elle se trompe la gauche elle doit
être dans le sens et poser la question
du sens sur tous ces millions et c'est
vrai que tous ces millions on se pose
des questions moi je me souviens deux
choses qui m'avaient frappé c'est
comment des des patrons millionnaires
avaient abandonné en une après-midi des
retraites chapeau ou des parachutes
dorés de plusieurs millions de francs ou
d'euros c'est arrivé en France quand
vous êtes capable d'abandonner une
retraite 8 millions 9 millions en une
après midi alors que de l'autre côté
vous avez des gens qui sont capables
d'aller voler des sandwichs à 5 euros
c'est qu'il y a un problème de sens là
dedans et c'est et c'est à mon avis
cette question c'est pas nécessaire de
seuil c'est une affaire de sens oui je
crois franchement entendre une France
100 milliardaires pour moi pardonnez-moi
mais ça n'a pas de sens c'est à dire que
ça voudrait dire d'abord que un certain
Horizon est empêché et boucher qu'on n'a
pas le droit de vouloir devenir riche en
vouloir devenir riche je suis désolé ça
peut faire partie des aspirations et
c'est aussi ce qui fait bouger une
société mais la question m'a tu as
raison la question c'est celle du
civisme des milliardaires comment le
système qui existe alors c'est aussi
bien le système fiscal que par exemple
les lois sur la philanthropie permettent
à ces grandes fortunes d'assumer un rôle
qui va avec l'importance de leur
richesse alors mais d'ailleurs aux
États-Unis il y a un classement des plus
gros donateurs c'est jamais parfait
parce que mais en France ça existe pas
quoi ça veut pas dire qu'il y a pas de
gros donateur mais il est absolument il
se cache je pense que la vraie question
à poser c'est celle là et puis il faut
pas oublier qu'il y a des fortunes qui
se sont aussi construites je dirais qui
ont servi la puissance française je vais
en citer une seule celle de Marcel
Dassault Marcel Dassault a fait une très
grande fortune à l'époque il l'a fait au
service de la puissance française dans
un domaine qui c'est celui le domaine de
la défense le domaine militaire donc ce
serait dire non milliardaire c'est en
plus risqué de soumettre le pays à
l'influence d'autres qui ont des
milliardaires donc qui ont un pouvoir de
puissance à levier très important grâce
à la richesse de leur compatriotes donc
je crois que ce serait très risqué vous
êtes d'accord tout à fait et ce qui me
frappe aujourd'hui c'est qu'on est quand
même dans un changement d'époque c'est
vrai que tous les milliardaires dont on
parle aujourd'hui sont des milliardaires
dans le développement vient à partir de
la fin des années 70 au début des années
80 j'allais dire c'est un peu les
enfants du taxialisme et du griganisme
c'est-à-dire que on
accroît la titrisation on tire tout vers
le marché boursier et vers des
capitalisations énormes là aujourd'hui
il y a quand même un gros changement
c'est que on voit bien la remontée des
frontières et ça c'est à l'échelle
globale c'est pas seulement en Europe on
voit bien la remontée de la
conflictualité et ça ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'il y a une reux
territorialisation des milliardaires et
ça va et ça a des impacts énormes parce
que ça veut dire que le chantage dont
vous parlez tout à l'heure de dire si je
me plaît pas ici je vais aller ailleurs
à partir du moment où les nations
commencent à se à se remonter un petit
peu partout et c'est le c'est quand même
ce qu'on constate la montée des
populismes un peu partout et bien ça
change le débat et ça pousse à une
contrainte et sans doute moi c'est mon
opinion c'est qu'à l'avenir dans un
avenir proche les très très grandes
fortunes vont en venir à devoir
négocier avec le système c'est à dire
faire des dons aider mettre à
disposition ce que certains d'ailleurs
ont déjà compris et commencent à faire
peut-être encore plus que qu'aujourd'hui
on termine là-dessus merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce à ce
débat Fabrice aménage rappelle le titre
de votre livre votre histoire mondiale
des riches qui est publiée chez plomb on
se retrouve tout à l'heure 22h ne ratez
pas notre émission spéciale consacrée à
l'allocution du Président de la
République invité politique expert en
communication politologue pour analyser
la forme et le fond du discours du chef
de l'État et puis notez aussi votre
prochain rendez-vous sur notre antenne
prochaine invité la députée LFI
Clémentine Autain sera dans la matinale
face à Oriane Mancini belle soirée à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]